de la musique avec le son chaud du
vinyle au sein de l'hôtel de ville de
versailles
ce week-end les amateurs de l'univers du
disque microsillon se sont donné rendez
vous à cette quatrième édition de vinyle
expo on est dans la musique depuis x
années on a vu qu'il y avait un retour
du vinyle qui n'a jamais cessé d'exister
et on a décidé de faire quelque chose
qui ne soit pas une convention c'est à
dire de réunir le vinyle
les disquaires nationaux internationaux
et l'univers du vinyle le matériel high
tech le matériel vintage des lampes en
vinyle dans des lieux prestigieux que
sont les mairies un jukebox moderne des
objets de décoration et encore du
matériel high tech
une soixantaine d'exposants étaient
présents pour plonger les visiteurs
venus nombreux dans cet univers du
vinyle ça nous permet de rencontrer
plein de monde
une visibilité supplémentaire c'est la
troisième fois qu'on travaille avec la
ville expose justement on a été à
levallois est à se demander où ça s'est
super bien passé donc on continue à
suivre à sur la lancée d'une élection
dès l'ouverture avoir du mal à trouver
ses vinyles près de faire et je pense
que c'est plutôt rassurant
rassurant pour le marché de mine il est
rassurant pour notre métier
les disquaires ont envahi l'espace de
leur bac ne restait plus qu'à fouiller
pour dénicher des pépites de tous les
styles musicaux il ya du choix et c'est
agréable de pouvoir chercher de voir on
peut trouver des choses intéressantes
bien durant ce week-end plus de 6000
visiteurs se sont réchauffées les
oreilles ovini expo à versailles